let's play a little bit on
um the telos uh i just want to play on
this
for a bit given the fact that we're
talking about simulation tech we're
given
ai vr tech emerging
what's being unleashed with quantum
computation
so ultimately it seems as though the way
that
a tree drops seeds and those become
trees in the way that a zygote makes a
human and humans procreate make more
humans
the same way that a big bang makes a
civilization and we make more big bangs
do you see the recursion as the telos
um do you see this as a quine in a sense
by telos do you mean some kind of like
purpose to the to the whole thing
yeah yeah i i think um
i mean i guess my view the recursion
comes in the kind of self-referential
nature of things comes in with life and
with
it's crucial for consciousness with you
know because we're we're kind of
self-starting
creatures we're um there is no we're
both the puppeteer and the puppet you
know of our of ourselves
uh but i see i think i see
that's actually a really interesting
product because i i would say that i see
the evolution of the universe
starting at the big bang as rather than
a kind of recursive process as quite a
kind of linear process like a kind of
like a radial process of like a flower
blooming or something where you have a
big bang and then you have
physics becoming becoming chemistry
becoming biology becoming
like just increasing complexity and it's
but it's this very um
i don't know aesthetically i like it as
well it makes me feel very like
reassured that the world is just moving
in one direction and
and it makes things feel less loopy and
and complicated
than the kind of quiet coin picture
because when you when you start
interesting consciousness you really
can't tumble down
you know holes of solipsism and you know
not knowing whether where the kind of
flaw is um of reality
but i would say yeah actually when it
comes to
so when it comes to reality itself
there's a sense in which we kind of
touched on earlier
you know newton had this idea that
everything the universe is made of
little separate things little separate
bricks they're truly separate
and then with quantum mechanics we now
know it's far more like an interwoven
tapestry
or like a house of cards where every
kind of piece is dependent
on all the other pieces and
consciousness is like that as well
i think this is how you can get
consciousness arising out of a physical
system because it's not like it
introduces a new substance into
existence
but at the level of information a system
can hold that the world is one way as
opposed to another way
it can hold that something as hot versus
cold but then there are correlations
with like
well hot things tend to be more red and
yellow you know there's like long
wavelengths of light rather than kind of
blues and greens
in this kind of self-referential process
you build up consciousness you
you you get this kind of house of cards
of more
this less of that and this is kind of
touched on the buddhist concept of
emptiness when you
in the west we have ideas of qualia the
idea that redness is a thing like
the idea of quality was supposed to be
like an atom of consciousness which
i think should sound like a kind of
nonsense idea red is only red
with respect to everything else in
consciousness you can't isolate it and
have just
just read um and so this is the buddhist
concept of emptiness that if you really
look at red for long enough
it loses any sense of any intrinsic
essence it's all just this kind of
mirage
of of relative relative change so i'd
say in that sense
i don't know if that's precisely the way
you mean this kind of this kind of
self-referential structure but i think
yeah everything emerges in this in this
way and it and it's part it's a feature
of a holistic
picture of things the holistic nature of
consciousness and the holistic nature of
the physical world as well
in inevitably it's going to happen
with the west becoming
uh more and more and even china
you know japan is a canary in the coal
mine in many ways with
humans passing i don't know if you've
seen the husk
but the husk is the the contraption now
for
for the ultimate uh unit where you're
literally
just you know you got your bed you got
your
computer you got your controller your
your you know you've got your whole
setup and and soon it's just you know
it's right in it's it's
it's connected directly in and and
you're
it if you don't put on vr
and use it for 30 minutes
and then take it off and think to
yourself
how am i not already in vr
then you don't know but if you do have
that process you take it off
and you in and you make the self-inquiry
and you go
how is this not already vr
then you know and and and i think that
that that is the essence of where um
the modernized world is pushing
and that the modernized world is going
to triangulate on the exact same
realization
that five thousand years ago four
thousand years ago three thousand years
ago from
everywhere across the world it's a
perennial spiritual wisdom
um it has been triangulating on so so um
we'll see and i and i do think that john
smart's transcension hypothesis has a
lot of um
of potential uh as well um
we've hit on so many awesome things i
want to um
um i want to talk about this for a bit i
think that you know
you've had incredible guests on your
show already i highly recommend
you guys to go and check out james's
podcast he's crushing it check out his
youtube channel
um christophe [ __ ] episode was so good
so was um
you know donald huffman both such great
episodes
if we take um if we take hoffman's
perspective for a little bit we were
talking about this a lit a bit before we
started
um it seems like a multimodal
user interface and the video game
analogy we were just talking about a
moment ago
um those are basically
anyone that has anyone that goes through
that process of self-inquiry we were
just talking about
inevitably comes to the realization that
they themselves
have a uh a user interface that they
are they're in a reality they have a
they have this user interface
there are um there are fitness functions
you know that if you
if you eat um a bucket
of ice cream um you're gonna feel like
[ __ ]
and that you're gonna feel like [ __ ] the
next day and that you're probably
shaving
um could be shaving a day or two or even
a week off of your longevity
um and now versus if you eat a salad
you're gonna feel great you'll feel
great tomorrow you'll
you might you know have an extra week on
so there's there's
there are um there are these
these understandings of um of what you
do
in this in this reality um is going to
inevitably um make you more peaceful
more happy
uh a better mate um more knowledge about
truth more um uh a better
better mate for procreation so the the
the i and i'm i'm also curious where
living mirrors theory
could potentially um synthesis with
the multimodal user interface because in
a sense that's what the cell
does have the cell has a a
alleged a ledger and an understanding of
the world and then it's constantly
updating that based on
fitness so do you see a synthesis of of
hoffman and and you and in a sense as
well i can see your headphonics
yeah i am so i think that's a really
really important point so
um yeah i would say once so when i was
an undergrad when i first was kind of
introduced to psychology and
neuroscience it was taught
kind of um that it was kind of a fact or
it's almost a
point of definition that colors are not
out there in the world
beauty is not out there in the world
things are not objectively colorful
objectively beautiful
um those are qualities that exist in
consciousness and this was just like
day one of like talking about perception
let's get our definition straight
if your leaves are not green you
perceive them to be green
but that's that's in consciousness right
um so when i first saw donald hoffman's
theory it took me a while just to
understand what he was saying was
radical
because when when he says again his
reality his name his book
and he was saying the world isn't
actually full of these colors i was like
well that's that's a fact basically like
i think if you're thinking about the
world the right way is that's
that's something yeah that's true but
then
it turns out he's saying something far
more radical that like you know the moon
isn't there when you're not looking at
it that kind of thing i think there's
something
even though it's not um it doesn't have
the same appearance like appearances
happen in consciousness i think there's
some structure
out there in the world that persists
when when we're not looking at it
but um but yeah so so this idea that
conscious the contents of consciousness
are absolutely
and i was basically only tied to fitness
payoffs is the term that hoffman uses
but like um so there's structure in the
world
and you perceive you know when you're
hungry you perceive
certain food to be appetizing and
delicious
and when you're not hungry you know if
you eat too much chocolate then the same
thing can now appear disgusting right
like your conscious perception
the attribute of the thing in the world
has changed yet it's not like physicists
have to account for some
you know um some atom that decays
from like nice atom to disgusting atom
you know
that's not how we think about the kind
of disgustingness or appetizing-ness of
the chocolate being out there in the
world
same's true for color seems true uh for
all these other things which is
you know that that's that was the way i
was thinking about consciousness when i
came up with my theory because
in my theories it's absolutely entirely
tied up with the organism's survival
and the contents of consciousness are
completely tied up with with what you
might call
fitness payoffs um and also i think to
just get a feeling of this kind of
the fact that what you perceive as an
interface for the world you know like
um if you perceive you know based on
your history and your kind of genetics
and stuff you might perceive
certain foods to be appealing because
because of that history and because it
makes sense for you
in the same way like you know imagine if
as well as us becoming this intelligent
technologically advanced civilization
imagine if slugs had as well
and you had you know slug hollywood
celebrities
who all the slugs agreed were the most
beautiful
perfect you know things they thought
they were like objectively beautiful i
don't think i would be agreeing that the
slug hollywood celebrities are
objectively
beautiful right and that's that's a way
of seeing that the perception the
conscious
perception of beauty is is not out there
in the world and
and as weird as it sounds it's true for
all of our
our senses and we saw this with the the
hysteria around um
that dress that went viral with the
color can i talk to you about it
beautiful good thank you for example i
was very excited when that
came up so i was like this is what i'm
interested in and this points to
something fascinating about the nature
of reality
exactly like you're poised on
understanding something
but then then the media kind of took it
in a far more like no no it's just this
this kind of you know some more kind of
a less radical kind of
ways it's like the biggest metaphysical
thing and yeah
exactly exactly and it and it's what you
can do from that point and the same
thing was with that um
that sound clip of yanny versus laurel
people heard it as these two different
words right
what you can realize that is that what
you're seeing is not
perception is not like you're looking
out of these transparent eyeballs to
a freestanding world james just
just one quick thing on that is that you
can change your
um perception to on the laurel yanny but
you
because you can you can go back and
forth like the reuben
um uh vase or the necker cube
um but on uh you can go back and forth
but on the
um uh the dress i i
you can't at least um from what i've
tested with people
they can't go back and forth between
gold and white
and black and blue which that i think is
the most profound part of it yeah anyway
uh yeah i mean yeah it's never that's
interesting in its own right i think it
might be to do with the fact that
like with the with the vase face
illusion where it kind of changes
there's some structure there that you
can scan your attention around and you
can
you have some model in your head of the
two things and you can you can kind of
actively engage with the process same
with the annie and laurel
you can really try and focus on the high
notes that sound like yanny
and all the low lots of laurel with the
dress it's more i think
the the thing that seems to account for
which way you go is
is if you think you're discounting blue
light or
yellow light i read one thing that's i
don't know if it was actually
uh real data or if it's just speculation
but there was this speculation that
that men would see it um
as i think it was black and blue oh no
sorry yellow and
um gold and white because they played
more computer games with blue lights so
their brain is used to
being like oh like the room's drenched
in blue light i better discount some
blue
and then it pushes it in that direction
um but uh
yeah i mean i don't know if that's
that's was actually proven but that's i
think that might be why it moves that
way
but uh but yeah so what it shows you
though is that this is not a pre-given
world that looks the way it looks
there is a screen of this consciousness
and there's all these weird appearances
inside it
and you are you are just another one of
these appearances you know when i'm
looking at my hand
it feels like this hand is inside me but
actually it's appearing in consciousness
it's it's visually continuous with the
rest of the background
and that's when you can your kind of
sense of self and blink out of existence
and there can just be this
kind of light of consciousness and a
bunch of phenomena happening and you can
realize that
fundamentally that's what's going on and
there's a delusion when you
you you know you take this bundle of
perceptions and you say this is me
these appearances of hands are me and
you know i'm saying there is an organism
but the organism is not the same thing
as the concept of the self
and it's the concept of the self that
all of our suffering is fed through you
know this was the kind of buddha's
insight
that neuroscience is now kind of showing
to be true as well right
so it could be fair to say that there
is a um within the
living mirror theory there is a
um uh the living system
has its uh a coupling with the
environment and
in that process the multimodal user
interface is what the living system uses
so there's that that's kind of what the
synthesis
could yeah and i would say just kind of
important to
the interface ideas that's important
because consciousness is not like you're
being aware of the thing out there
what it is is the thing out there is
utterly beyond your boundary you know
your hair is this kind of bounded
physical system photons might fall on
your retina
but you know your insides your brain
everything else is just utterly in the
dark
and so consciousness is this active
creative
generative kind of hallucinatory process
and when you understand that the world
doesn't have an appearance it kind of
gives you
an appreciation as to why it's possible
for consciousness to exist
because it's not it's not like um
there's a thing
and i have a symbol for the thing and
how does my symbol become conscious
that's how a lot of people think about
this stuff
you know it's the kind of computer
analogy it's like there's some symbol
over here and there's some real thing
over here like say that there's a green
object and there's a symbol saying green
why does this symbol become
conscious whereas in a computer it
doesn't why doesn't the word green when
i write it down
why doesn't that become conscious
whereas i'm saying no like there is no
green thing
there's patterns and then you
consciousness is fundamentally you're
generating yeah like a simulation
generating an interface of beliefs about
the way the world is that is this
kind of house of cards of like uh saying
it's this way as opposed to this way so
it's entirely
uh generated within the organism well
through interacting with this
environment
but it's it's not um the each
each percept is is only cashed out in
reference to all the other percepts it's
this like relativistic framework
i've i've really appreciated um a way of
um of perceiving it regarding um
when you're when you're under when
you're at a
uh an event where you're you know you're
you're at whether it does literally just
take any
uh sports or music style event in a
stadium
and you're gonna have a different
point of view than somebody sitting
across the stadium
and when when you also register
that um you're gonna get that
at a at a deeper level that it's not
some um
uh that that you and when
all you got to play game i feel like you
gotta if you really dive in
like we didn't have the tool of games we
had it but we didn't have
you know this is the game changer is
that when you
it's literally the screen like the
screen as an
analogy the game as an analogy to
this is exactly what makes us
realize that when i go into the
the the the first person perspective
in in in and i'm playing and i'm playing
the game and i'm and i'm walking around
in the in the simulated world and i have
this
the the relationship between me as a
living system and my environment and my
interface and all of the
all of the stuff that i have in my
parcel that i'm my that i'm carrying
around with me
and that i have these quests and these
objectives and
that the more that you kind of follow
that uh train of thinking the more that
you're gonna realize that
james is also a player
and james also has his little um
world that that james is playing in as
well and james is going to see things
like
you are you is it is that it are you is
that your
girlfriend or is that the fiance or wife
what level or
life yeah life okay wife wife what's her
name
hey rebecca rebecca so um that you know
you have a wife you have
you know you have a wife you have a
rebecca like you you have
like you have that in your life i don't
have like a wife
so like my like the fact that we like
that you have a wife and i don't like
that is like a significant reality
changer
and so um like that's like that's
something to like
keep in mind like somebody that's living
in a completely different country
is basically on in a sense their reality
has a significantly different um
like you're in you're mostly in london
and in the mountains of portugal
and so you're you're inevitably going to
have
a different map than uh california in
the midwest and stuff like that so
um but but but there's also there's some
there's a synthesis between if we don't
break it down in two there's a synthesis
where
it's like in order for us to um have
this zoom call
we have to respect the objectivity
of the science that is occurring that is
enabling
the um the the computation the
um the the electromagnetic
um so you you you you have a a synthesis
that's going on if we want to agree that
the h2o molecule
um looks a specific way or that the the
cellular respiration and um and the
oxygen cycle on the planet happens
a specific way for for for every person
that
inhales the though too i think that that
there's gonna be a synthesis between
those
um those individual gamers
uh in their worlds with the fact that
all of those gamers are inhaling
um o2 and their hearts are beating a
hundred thousand times a day
stuff like that yeah i think um and also
the idea of being the kind of gamer with
the headset on you you mentioned earlier
the kind of
simulation stuff um which obviously is
the name of the podcast as well so maybe
it's relevant to
touch on that um but yeah i think i
think it's interesting that i i guess
it's not something i've dwell on very
much because um i think it's the uh
the thing we spoke about before where i
was saying like as a scientist it's like
i'll map out what what's within my
domain like so the before the big bang
we might be you know i mentioned earlier
ways of thinking about
why anything's happening at all and i'm
happy to speculate about that
but then you know like what happened for
the big bang is just kind of outside my
window
um what you know what happens in the
future is as well
uh so i i think like i guess i see
science as mapping out
this little space we're in now and most
people think it's the entire space right
they think big bang
this thing and that's it i i suspect
there's you know like why wouldn't there
be vast amounts of stuff going on
outside of
our window i see no reason why you
wouldn't think
whether you want to call it multiverses
or simulations within simulations within
simulations to me that seems
absolutely you know if not um plausible
likely you know that something
weird is happening um before
uh i think before certain psychedelic
experiences i would have said there's no
reason to
speculate like it's just it's
speculation it's like saying
am i a solipsist and then you can have
experiences where you seem to wake up
from the simulation and
that that definitely gives you that kind
of strange loop
idea of like wait like is this some is
the simulations all the way down and
you know you can kind of tumble through
them through some way but i think i
ultimately come back to kind of knowing
my place as a scientist and thinking
i'm gonna if this is a simulation it's a
beautiful
pretty complex simulation that's really
relevant for our day-to-day living so
i'm gonna try and
understand this one as best as i can if
at the end i wake up take my headset off
and go wow i can't believe that was a
game uh
i don't think i'll have i'll feel like
i've wasted my time in trying to
trying to understand the game yeah
and which plays very beautifully into
what we
mentioned uh earlier on uh infinity
making a infinite amount of illusory
finity and that plays into the
multiverse um perfectly
um there's just and and it also plays
perfectly in the sense of if you believe
in yourself as infinite potential that
there
is um every single possibility of you
and uh is happening right now and and
also every single possibility
in a in a non-uh anthropocentric way
is also happening so when you see all of
these designer
worlds that the video game artists are
making
all of those are happening as well and
we ourselves
are going to become more and more like
designers of worlds and we ourselves are
going to come to the realization more
and more of what infinity
truly is yeah
i think that that thing you said about
nature as infinite possibility
like i've been reflecting recently on
i've not tried to put this into words
but
there's a so i i don't believe i believe
that kind of
organism level um to use that term uh
libertarian free will the idea that you
know we can we can really choose exactly
what we want to do with no prior causes
kind of causing it i think that's an
illusion and it's a kind of
it's trying to kind of make ourselves
feel comfortable in our in our feeling
of separation but if you look at
the kind of the the freedom of the
totality of existence
and you consider the way that particles
interact and
anything happens from that perspective
everything the way that things interact
is the perfect choice given what they
are
like this is kind of what a scientific
picture of the world is it's like a
lawful thing it's like
given these things and their forces and
and what they are in themselves
they will the universe is utterly free
to do
exactly what is the most like lawful
or most um appropriate thing for it to
do
so you can think of of when you identify
with all of reality as there being this
kind of
ultimate freedom ultimate creative
fulfillment of the process just just
moving forward
in terms of what it is and what's best
for what it is which is another way of
describing determinism
which is a weird thing to say is that
like that you know from one side from
the human
idea of separation the idea of the
universe deciding everything is like oh
no that seems scary
that seems like you know i don't like
that idea but the idea of
the universe being ultimately free and
therefore manifesting its
what is most within its own nature is i
think is a really
yeah it it to me gives a scientific wave
maybe it's the scientific language
heading to what you just said about
identifying that kind of infinite
potential identifying with that
and you're spot on too and i'm i'm glad
that you
made content again everybody check out
james's channel
i'm glad that you made content
specifically about your
entheogenic experiences i think that's
extremely important the more that
um people feel like they are comfortable
it's almost like we're having a species
coming out of the closet in a sense
around around
the use of uh unleashing the divine
within via these
sacred secretions um of the planet and
and it's it's extremely important i'm
glad that you've made content about it
you've been vulnerable about i think
it's very important
and that's also going to triangulate
right on that that same
nature of reality